[Música]
y seguimos analizando varias aristas de
este conflicto entre rusia ucrania y
occidente ya está conmigo en el estudio
más romeros a la mar y hoy vamos a
hablar de algo pues realmente triste no
los más afectados y es la crisis de
refugiados que empezó con este ataque
ruso sobre ucrania que sabemos de lo que
está sucediendo con esta población en
este momento mar pues son buenos días
raúl para empezar lo venimos avanzando
en las noticias también estamos hablando
ya de 660 mil personas las que están
huyendo de ucrania los países de esos
alrededores el acnur recientemente decía
también que hay 60 kilómetros de fila
por ejemplo para poder cruzar los brazos
los pasos fronterizos entre ucrania y
polonia entre otros y pues sabemos que
es una de las veces que ha aumentado más
rápidamente la cifra de personas
refugiadas en la historia de lo que se
viene registrando más de la mitad de
estas personas que huyen se van hacia
polonia pero también están huyendo hacia
hungría rumanía eslovaquia en el mapa
ven los países de la unión europea que
están recibiendo ahora mismo flujo de
personas pero es importante recordar que
hay un centenar de mil de un centenar y
bueno tiene mil personas aproximadamente
que están oyendo hacia rusia desde hace
unos ocho años debido a la guerra que
hay en la región del donbass sin embargo
pues la mayor parte buscan refugio en la
unión europea siguiendo con el discurso
ucraniano y la verdad es que la unión
europea los está acogiendo con los
brazos abiertos mari también hay que dar
otra cifra y es que se estima que si
esto continúa así hasta 4 millones de
personas son las que pueden seguir
emigrando huyendo de este conflicto pero
le pregunto entonces hablando de estos
países europeos que acogen los migrantes
qué medidas hay para acoger a todos
estos refugiados pues sabemos que todos
los países están preparando precisamente
para acoger a este gran flujo de
personas que están huyendo de una guerra
por un lado hay la solidaridad de las
personas hay muchísima autoorganización
para ayudar a las personas que cruzan a
un países que no son los suyos pero es
que por otro lado los gobiernos también
se están esforzando en dejar claro que
van a acoger a todas las personas que lo
necesiten de hecho la unión europea
plantea una decisión siempre antes que
es activar una directiva internacional
que permitiría acoger a todas las
personas que lleguen de ucrania sin
necesidad de que hagan una solicitud de
asilo les darían protección inmediata
por un año extendible a tres y les
darían pues cobertura social permisos de
trabajo y escolarización para los
menores de edad mari también con estos
conflictos pues hay que hay que ver el
lado bueno sacar la solidaridad y la
buena parte de nosotros los humanos una
buena noticia no que tanta gente esté
dispuesta a hacer más leve esta crisis a
ayudar a las personas que realmente los
necesitas y lamentablemente también pues
gracias a la humanidad cuando hay una
situación adversa ahí salimos todos a
ser solidarios mientras tanto pues cada
quien sigue con su vida y uno es un poco
más duro pues por supuesto de hecho esa
no es una maravillosa noticia que haya
tantas personas que han decidido ayudar
y sobre todo a las personas que no
tienen los recursos y que no tienen
ningún tipo de responsabilidad tampoco
no en este conflicto pero también la
verdad es que es una noticia con un
regusto agridulce
raúl y es que hay varios reportes que
han inundado las redes sociales sobre
las dificultades que están teniendo
cruzar las fronteras personas racial
izadas personas que no son blancas que
vivían en ucrania que también se han
visto atrapados por este conflicto está
siendo muy difícil contrastar todas
estas denuncias hay reporteros sobre el
terreno que dicen que en realidad lo
único que sucede es que se separan en
dos filas los ucranianos de los neutra
nia nos con fines administrativos otros
dicen en cambio que si hay problemas
sobre todo de parte de los soldados
ucranianos no podemos contrastar todas
estas denuncias pero entendiendo que el
racismo es una cosa estructural en
nuestra sociedad deberíamos estar
preparados para que este tipo de
problemas surjan en estos días y en
estos momentos de tanta tensión el
gobierno polaco se ha pronunciado para
decir que va a dejar entrar a todo el
mundo y que esas órdenes son los que
tienen sus soldados y sus guardias
fronterizos pero las denuncias son tan
amplias que hasta la unión africana se
ha pronunciado para decir que pues
parece escandalosamente racista que haya
este tipo de problemas en las fronteras
piden que se deje acoger a todo el mundo
por igual un reclamo el que se sumó la
organización internacional para las
migraciones en las últimas horas que
recordó que no puede haber tratos
diferenciales pero es que más allá del
actualiza tivo son personas que están en
este territorio estampado lo mismo así
es
pero tampoco es la primera vez que la
unión europea se enfrenta a una crisis
de refugiados le pregunto entonces las
diferencias entre las anteriores ya está
claro es que de ahí estamos sacamos esto
del racismo estructural no es la primera
vez que algo así puede suceder y es una
de las contradicciones que se le están
señalando al bloque europeo como han
abierto los brazos a refugiados
ucranianos pero con otras personas de
medio oriente de siria del continente
africano no lo hicieron no hace falta ir
muy atrás hace solo unos meses de entre
polonia y belarús un montón de migrantes
unos miles aproximadamente 40.000
migrantes fueron usados la verdad por el
gobierno de alexandr lukashenko para
crear una problema en la frontera entre
belarús y polonia y polonia en ningún
caso aceptó esos migrantes
al contrario básicamente lo que hicieron
fue interceptar sus cruces unos 30.000
cruces se desplazaron soldados para
hacer frente a gente indefensa y hasta
se destinaron 32 millones de euros raúl
a construir un muro algo que contrasta
mucho con la situación actual así es mar
y al final es no un problema de estos
países fronterizos sino de toda la unión
hay que ver qué va entonces a pasar a
medida que pasa el tiempo y todo lo que
hace en estos países para acoger a la
mayor cantidad de refugiados gracias mar
por toda la información pasamos a
saludar a nuestro segundo invitado del
día